we have now an indication that we are
working on
uh that we are hoping uh very much that
we can start clinical trials in patients
and
uh in in children in particular in order
to uh relieve the suffer and help them
and help their families
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today we're going to be talking
about medical research and we welcome
rami akilan
born in east jerusalem dr ramya killian
is a full professor of immunology and
cancer research at the hebrew university
hadassah medical school in jerusalem he
began his academic career at the
university of jordan where he received
the bsc in biology followed by a masters
and phd from the hebrew university
hadassah medical school
in 2008 he joined the faculty of
medicine at the hebrew university of
jerusalem currently he is the head of
the institute for medical research
israel canada
[Music]
ramyakilan welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you
good good thank you mikhail
thank you very very much for being here
you were born in east jerusalem now
you're a full-time professor of
immunology and cancer research at the
hebrew university hadassah medical
school and but you you've had an
incredible journey across a variety of
academic institutions the research that
you're doing is fascinating and is
obviously you know um already has made
an impact and it's continuing to make an
impact on people that have you know
unfortunately
a lot of different illnesses and so i'm
excited to hear a little bit about what
drives you and and and even more excited
to hear about you know the research that
you're doing and so tell me a little bit
about you know your own journey and take
walk me through your your life sort of
and what guides you through your
different experiences
yeah sure well thank you very much for
having me first and it's really a great
honor
uh so as you said i was born in east
jerusalem actually in chief java
and grew up
there at high school i did my bachelor
at the university of jordan
then joined the hebrew university as a
master and a phd student
[Music]
working on cancer research but
during my high school actually in the
10th grade
i got to meet this teacher who made me
love biology
and his lessons i would wait for this
lesson all the time to hear and learn
new things about
the cells how they function all these
organelles all these reactions i loved
also chemistry but
biology was just talking to me more
so
i i decided i want to go and learn more
about
you know um
life about what's going on within these
cells and
slowly slowly i was getting more and
more interested in uh mechanisms of
diseases how how things get really worry
and and what really drives them out of
this order that is
placed in in a normal cell now tell me
yeah
going back to high school this biology
now
do you get excited by this because of
the teacher style or is it just is it
more the material that really draws you
well actually the teacher just made the
material so exciting so
i think he got just this uh style
that made me really love more and more
the material and
pushed me to ask more questions and
uh get to be more and more curious so
it is a combination i would say but you
know there is always a mean for
something and and that was the mean for
me to love more of uh this material
okay so walk me through then your your
academic career because you you get
enticed by this idea of biology and
cells and diseases and how it impacts us
as humans and you know you know any any
living thing in general walk me through
a little bit about about you know your
academic experience and what draws you
more and more into it
yeah so so i finished biology and i was
really not sure what i'm gonna do with
this okay i love it
uh i never saw myself as a professor or
as uh an academician
i actually went back to jerusalem and
started working in uh
in cuba
in like
one of the medical centers in the old
city of jerusalem
and i hated it i didn't like this type
of work
so and i was
all the time wanting to go back to
school and this is where uh my father
actually pushed me to
go and and find out about hebrew you and
this is where i
first started my master then i moved
directly to a phd program
um
looking at targeted therapy looking at
how we can selectively eliminate cancer
cells it was just fascinating
for me
and during this time i just made up my
mind that this is the way to go and it
is not enough now i have to go to a
postdoc so this is what we usually do
after phd
and the the place to do it is usually
abroad and this is uh
why i chose to go to
usa
and there i joined the
the lab of carlo croce one of the known
and famous
scientists
on cancer genetics
he was in philadelphia at the kimmel
cancer center
i started my postdoc fellowship there in
in 2002 sorry
and moved with him to ohio state
university
at ohio state i started my
first faculty position stayed there for
four years
and you know family home
so we decided to go back and started
my job at hebrew you at the same place
where i studied my
master in phd it was very exciting
[Music]
at the medical school
and started my lab
you know there is a hierarchy and there
is a stepwise
to build in the university so
i moved from a senior
lecturer to associate professor the full
professor
today i'm heading actually the institute
for medical research israel canada
an institute that
has about 100
220 principal investigators
working on different disciplines
in
medical research
and
i have my own lab my own research i
would love to tell you more about this
if you like i'm i am ready for it but so
before you tell me about you know your
lab in your research tell me a little
bit about you know what you studied all
these years in it as simply as possible
so that both i and and whoever's
listening can understand because you
know immediately you know
when i'm preparing for a talk like this
and i'm thinking about you know the work
that you're doing you're talking about
it can't you know selectively selective
cells and cancer and immunology i
immediately think like wow this is so
complicated there's no way i'll
understand it so so dumb it down for me
a little bit what is it all about
it's all about what goes wrong so a
normal cell become crazy
and
cannot be uh
like control so this was what interests
me to know what are the very early steps
that happens in a normal cell changing
it from this
being normal and behaving well to become
just
so uncontrolled in growth in uh in in
behavior and signaling in
in things that it's supposed not to do
it
so i was very curious to learn about
this very initial step what happens to
the dna
our dna what regions really there are to
be affected the first in
in our dna in order to make this
cell become cancerous
uh
so we started we we studied many we
looked at the microscope on many cells
and we changed some of the dna of these
cells and tried to predict and to prove
whether these changes that we think of
could really get these cells to be
uncontrollable
that was just one aspect then of course
uh we
we like i like to build models because
uh
if you want to to study uh a theme you
you need a model for it and this is
applicable to everything
and the models that we do usually in the
lab is either animal models so we use
mouse models for example to study cancer
or
we use other non
animal models
simple or more complicated based on cell
culture
uh
and and try to
mimic this change that we think of and
see what are the consequences of this
change that we are introducing on the
cell phase or on the uh whole organism
and so this is the research that you're
doing today right
so this is the research so we our
research very much look into what we
know in the medical field as
a genome stability and genomic
instability that is
uh
seen in
namely in cancer but now there is also
more and more interest to study these
changes in other diseases none
not necessarily cancerous
and we study this regions in the genome
that are called fragile
regions and these as the name predict
they are more vulnerable to
breaks to changes to what we call
mutations
um
and try to look what is really residing
in these regions in the genome
there are genes that we know of and
these genes
should have a function should be there
for a certain reason so we try to
characterize these genes and to
understand their function
and again we we do this in cells
in
like uh sometimes in sophisticated cells
that we design or we reprogram
but also in a whole organism and a whole
animal to see
if we change this
gene
that is found in this very specific
fragile region in the genome what would
be the consequences on tumor formation
on
brain homeostasis
and because again as i said there are so
many evidence linking these genes and
these mutations with diseases for
example cancer but also we recently
started to work on childhood epilepsy
because of genes that are very important
to
maintain
the homeostasis of the central nervous
system
turned out that many of these genes that
are critical for cancer they also have
other functions
in other diseases or in other tissues or
in other cells for example they are
critical for type 2 diabetes or they're
critical for the central nervous system
and if they are mutated or they are
there are changes they can cause
epilepsy or alzheimer's disease or
parkinson's and so on and so on
that makes sense and so one of the
things that i'm always curious about
first of all it sounds fascinating and
one of the things that i'm always
fascinated on is you know outcomes of
research especially in academic
institutions especially in health and
medicine you know as you're running this
lab and you're running this research
much like an entrepreneur needs to or a
ceo needs to what is sort of the how do
you measure yourself how do you measure
progress how are you lead what is a
leader do you do to keep the team
focused and and what is sort of the end
goal of a research like this
yeah so let's start from the end and i
think the what satisfies really a
researcher is
to have a better understanding of the
mechanisms
of action of
of
whatever
we study
but then i think the most satisfying at
least for me
is
really to be able to translate this
basic knowledge that we understand to
use
to benefit the the patient and this is
what we call in science translational
science or translational medicine so we
study the genes we study the cells and
the mouse and
everything on the bench but eventually
we would like to translate to the bed to
the patient and this is where i see that
we are heading in our research because
the knowledge that we have
gathered and we have invested to
understand
is now
we are in the phases of translating this
to help patients
and i was very lucky to have an
excellent group of students and postdocs
that really work very hard in the lab
and also
contribute to the brainstorming of
whatever we do and also explore
ways to translate our ideas in order to
help the patients we have now an
indication that we are working on
uh that we are hoping
very much that we can start clinical
trials in patients and in in children in
particular in order to uh relieve the
suffer and help them and help their
families
so i think if this is gonna gonna work
i will be extremely
uh
you know
high satisfied uh
name it like this would be really an
excellent achievement uh for humanity
and for science and for scientists
and how do you deal with the fact you
know more on a personal level how do you
deal with the fact that it could turn
out that the research doesn't work that
you might
spend months or years working on
something that doesn't materialize into
a finding that you hope
you would achieve
well you know this is you this is
usually the norm actually the normal
situation is that things doesn't work
somehow because
the models that we build are not perfect
and there is always something else to
know or to to understand or to discover
in order to perfect this model and it's
only a model so
we
we kind of
get used to this but of course
we never gave up because uh we need to
uh be persistent and this is uh
something about me also and about i
think every successful person you need
to be persistent you need to insist you
need to believe in what you're doing
and by only having this
feelings you can really keep going and
try again and troubleshoot and start
over and uh
and make it work
right
and so as a researcher
do you what type of tools do you use
with your team you know more on a
leadership level to to help guide
guide them through this process both on
a professional but also on a personal
level
well i think uh we have an excellent
relationship with the uh with the team
members it's about
you know having these uh
brainstorming together uh mentoring
at the different stages of their
studies and eventually career
so a lot of meetings a lot of
interaction social activity
going to conferences not as
much now in the covet time but
um
eventually this is some somebody that
you build from
studying as an undergrad or most of the
students start in the lab but then
becoming a graduate then
follow following them
in their
future career becoming postdocs and
eventually also independent researchers
but interaction
and
talking
brainstorming mentoring i think these
are all the
kind of stuff that
we do in order to ensure that the
students develop and get to become
really next generation leaders
i love it so ramen take me back a little
bit back to biology classes
and in high school and even before that
you know it's a gift to know where your
passion lies already in high school and
and most
i don't believe that most to have it
where how did this affect your life back
then how did it change the way that you
experienced the world you know from
before you've discovered this field to
after
it is really uh
um
it was a journey to to go through
and i think uh
to
mature through this uh journey and to
realize that this is really what i love
i love to
better understand and to
be able to
make a change even if it is a small
change
uh
and and you know i i like doing small
steps
uh and i think this is uh exactly
what i went through so small steps
uh with dedication with
persistence uh
and and you got there and i think
the the
the more that you believe in what you're
doing the the more that you will get
there
and you will achieve and uh get to your
goals
i'm hoping i addressed your question 100
now you've touched on this a little bit
about where you draw your current
inspiration from
besides you know the potential impact
that you may have with with this
research post clinical trials and
everything
what really inspires you in your day to
day about your work
um
i'm inspired by
every day by learning something new
so
i'm a believer
and i um
i just love
to explore the beauty of creation and
the beauty of what is going on around us
and every day
i i like to
learn something new and i'm learning
something new and this really keeps me
going on to learn more to discover more
uh to help
and seeing you know the fruits of what
you're doing is always motivates
motivation to keep going ahead so i love
it yeah i like it
and what are a few words that you would
use to describe yourself if you had to
uh to describe myself um
okay this is tough but
you know i i don't give up
i like to uh
i like challenges
and uh
you know
i've been through many challenges in my
life
uh and
i think uh
i'm very
persistent and
spontaneous
i would say
and uh
i love my family
and
from there i also get a lot of energy
and my wife and my
children my father my mother who passed
away so
i'm just you know a normal kid
rami thank you very very much this was
inspiring best of luck with the research
best of luck one of the political trials
and i can't wait to keep in touch and
see the progress and stay safe and stay
healthy thank you
thank you
thank you very much